[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue en point de vue
c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver pour
notre émission quotidienne autour ce
soir de deux invités bonsoir laurent
alexandre vous êtes médecin
entrepreneurs essayiste votre dernier
livre jouissez jeunesse a été publié aux
éditions lattès plus nous avons aussi le
plaisir de recevoir georges kuzmanovic
bonsoir bonsoir vous avez été porte
parole de la france insoumise il vous
est désormais président du mouvement que
vous avez fondé république souveraine
tout commence en si vous le voulez bien
par revenir sur cet entretien
extrêmement fort donné par la jeune
milla à notre consoeur audrey
crespo-mara c'était hier soir sur tf1
mais là vous savez si cette jeune fille
qui avait critiqué de façon très
virulente très crus l'islam et le coran
et qui depuis est l'objet de milliers de
menaces de mort elle est sous protection
policière
elle ne peut pas sortir de chez elle le
sent mettre une perruque dit-elle sinon
elle est identifiée et ce serait trop
dangereux
personne ne sait où elle habite elle est
très amer sur ce qu'elle vit mais aussi
sur la façon dont peut-être notre pays
ne l'a pas suffisamment protégé écoutez
la nation est fragile et la shg employer
ce terme et je ne mâche un mémo j'étais
pourtant persuadé qu'on paie il n'était
pas comme ça si on sert pas les coudes
que ce soit même la majorité silencieuse
qui me soutient mais qui ne fera jamais
rien je sais des gens que j'apprécie
merci de me soutenir mais je vois la
lâcheté partout autour de moi personne
ne fait rien ce que les gens ont peur
les gens ont peur personne ne fait rien
peut-être ce jugement est il un peu trop
sévère c'est en tout cas l'idée le point
de vue plus exactement de michel barnier
et ce responsable des républicains qui
allie des négociateurs de l'union
européenne pour le break cité qui est
presque candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22
non je ne crois pas que notre nation
soit lâche
ce qui est arrivé à ces deux jeunes
femmes est insupportable ceux qui l'ont
harcelé doivent être condamnée fermement
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse dire que
notre pays et lâche la liberté
d'expression est un droit fondamental
dans notre république qui doit être
respectée donc voilà pourquoi je pense
que ceux qui ont harcelé cette jeune
femme doivent être sanctionnés sans que
je n'ai d'ailleurs ils sont ont
probablement l'être puisque il y à un
jugement qui est en cours de ceux d'un
certain nombre de personnes qui ont
menacé de mort mila et celle ci
d'ailleurs dit que depuis le début de
des audiences eh bien les menaces ont
repris de plus belle qu'elle est votre
point de vue sur ce qu'on a vu c'est ce
que vous trouvez que il y a une forme de
lâcheté collective dans ce qui arrive à
cette jeune fille que la ferme il a été
très compliqué il faut rappeler que
c'est une jeune fille qui a 18 ans et
qui était mineur au moment de ces
tragédies qui est arrivé et que nous
comme vous souhaite beaucoup d'autres on
lui a apporté une importante de soutien
en tant que personnes citoyennes
françaises libres de s'exprimer même à
dire n'importe quoi et à blasphémer et
qu'elle n'a pas à être menacés de mort
et que ceci doit être sanctionné
durement il se fait quand même que
l'état la protège puisque les protégés
par la police que des procédures ont été
mises en place pour poursuivre certains
de ceux qui l'ont menacé de mort donc on
ne fait pas rien et je trouve un peu
étrange reconnaître c'est parce qu'elle
est très jeune nous considérait que la
france et lâche
je pense qu'elle est beaucoup plus face
à la menace islamiste dans sa relation
avec les kurdes qui ont combattu des
champs première ligne qui ont repris
jaca et qui ont été lâchés en rase
campagne face aux turcs qui les
bombardent allègrement tous les jours là
on a un vrai phénomène de lâcheté de de
la france
voilà maintenant je trouve que milla est
un petit peu utilisé par certains car si
je me rappelle bien on a on a des gens
comme une usine à gaz oui mohamed
sifaoui monsieur luisi ou gilles kepel
qui sont protégés également par la
police car il sent menacée de mort
méheut s'attaque très spécifiquement et
de manière précise aux islamistes aux
frères musulmans aux salafistes
alors que il a bon étant jeune insultent
l'islam en général on connaît pas le
droit de le faire mais on n'est pas
obligé de considérer que c'est que c'est
du génie politique
laurent alexandre on l'a entendu il a
dit la nation est fragile et lâche
elle ne dit pas l'état est fragile et
l'âge peut-être parce que elle considère
est sans doute à juste titre que george
kaufmann de vie je le rappelais l'état a
fait son travail dans la protégeant mais
la nation et lâche parce que dans la
france de 2021
quand on critique trop fortement l'islam
en est en danger de mort et que ça c'est
une sorte de constat d'échec collectif
terrible il faut bien voir que les
religions monothéistes n'aime pas
beaucoup le blasphème
la dernière condamnation à mort par la
justice en france pour blasphème 1 c'est
le chevalier de la barre sous luis sulu
15 un petit peu avant l'arrivée au
pouvoir de louis saez le chevalier de la
barre avait insulté dieu il avait
blasphémer ils étaient condamnés à mort
en première instance et en appel et ont
considéré à l'époque de critiquer dieu
méritait la mort au milieu de 1766 voilà
c'est juste précédent les chiffres 1766
il est c'était un jeune homme il avait
il s'était ya 250 ans il avait il avait
20 ans et il a été tué pour avoir dit du
mal de dieu donc après le délit de
blasphème n'a plus conduit à la peine de
mort en france mais finalement il ya 250
ans l'église en france et le roi et le
pouvoir royal se comportaient vis-à-vis
des blasphémateurs comme le monde arabo
musulman se comportent aujourd'hui
vis-à-vis des sénateurs donc je veux
dire c'est quelque chose qui a existé en
france la mort la mort la mort pour
blasphème
alors aujourd'hui je
je pense qu'il y à un malentendu dans la
société française
je pense que les gens n'ont pas compris
à quel point le blasphème est très mal
supporté dans l'islam et la france
laïque eux libres penseuses va se
heurter à ce refus du blasphème dans
l'islam
et d'ailleurs on voit dans les jeunes
générations un pourcentage élevé des
jeunes français qui pensent que le
blasphème n'est pas moral est n'est pas
autorisé à bhl donc on a là un chant
classique locale sarah avons peu dire
oui bien sûr par rapport aux années 60
où le blasphème était quelque chose de
parfaitement accepté aujourd'hui les
jeunes générations considère que le
blasphème
c'est mal en réalité la petite mila elle
sera bientôt minoritaire dans la
jeunesse au nom du respect des croyants
au nom du respect des croyances et puis
du changement démographique majeur
l'islam devient truc tout tout doucement
en france la première religion pratiquée
enfin elle le sera d'ici 2050
on a d'un côté une déchristianisation
très forte et puis une montée en
puissance de la de l'adhésion à l'islam
notamment sur les jeunes générations
contrairement à ce qu'on imaginait il ya
30 ou 40 ans donc moi personnellement en
tant que laïque athée tout ça ne
m'enthousiasme pas mais je suis persuadé
que la france va devoir faire des
aménagements et que dans quelques
décennies il est probable que le
blasphème soit interdite en france
compte tenu de l'énorme modifications
démographiques qui est en cours
il n'y aura pas de majorité politique en
2060 en france pour autoriser le
blasphème
je pense que la loi l'interdît rats dans
le futur est ce que c'est juste juste un
dernier mot on voit cette évolution
politique dans le virage à 180° de
jean-luc mélenchon
on a tous connu un jean luc mélenchon
francs-maçons laïque athée aujourd'hui
son discours est quand même assez proche
des islamo gauchiste et il n'a jamais
condamné dans son parti les tentations
islamo islamo gauchiste pour des raisons
électoralistes que l'on connaît tous
donc c'est un changement de fond dans la
société française les politiques ne
soutiendront pas les blasphémateurs
parce que les voix des banlieues sont
nécessaires et que dans les banlieues et
bien le blasphème contre
le prophète et contre mahomet ne sera
pas acceptée dans quelques décennies
c'est une réalité sociologique et
démographique il va falloir s'y faire
qu'on en soit content ou qu'on n'en soit
pas content parce que l'avant et c'est
bien la france a soumis en avait pas
pour cette partie là mais vous pouvez
non mais la france est soumise à suis
suivi la fois que vous avez décrite jeu
les critiquer il ya deux ans et demi et
elle c'est ça que vous êtes partie entre
autres et elle s'est trompée c'est une
erreur c'est un calcul électoral qui ne
rapporte rien car des électeurs l'islam
n'est pas un monolithe et on peut pas
essentialiser une religion qui est sur
plus d'une cinquantaine de pays avec
quasiment un milliard de croyants ou
incroyants la laïcisation est en progrès
dans les pays musulmans et nous avons
accueilli en france
d'innombrables musulmans en particulier
algériens qui ont fui les exactions du
fils et je peux vous dire que les
haillons ce qui était la france
insoumise étaient les plus radicaux pour
s'opposer maintenant mais de la manière
des 1000 combe aux islamistes en france
comme ils sont militaires cela non parce
que les sondages bd10 d'alexandrie
finance pas il ya de plus en plus de
gens qui disent parmi les musulmans
notre nôtre
nos convictions sont au dessus de la rue
pelée valeurs comme la laïcité ils sont
toujours minoritaires et je ne pense pas
que ce soit qu'un problème de l'islam
c'est aussi un problème de l' influence
de la culture anglo saxonne qui passe
par les sites comme les séries
télévisées qui présente un monde qui est
mû par la vision multi multi culturelle
ne tarit communautariste et identitaire
identitaire dans tous les domaines même
quand c'est du médiéval fantastique
c'est toujours abordé sous cet angle là
ils ont bien le droit c'est leur monde
mais ça a fait énormément de dégâts
aussi et c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'autant de jeunes sont dans cette
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi est ce que
l'on critiquerait anglaise freinerait
contre une religion
et là je suis pas d'accord avec vous
enfin en tout cas j'espère que ça ne se
passera pas comme ça
et si d'aventuré cela prendrait cette
tournure mais je prends ce qu'il
faudrait faire
à ceux qui voudraient imposer un islam
politique en france la même chose qui
est ce qui a été fait à ceux qui
défendent et le catholicisme politique
en france et nous avons été extrêmement
durs et je crois que je les rattrape les
deux ou trois fois ici à d'autres
endroits si on se réfère à ce qui s'est
passé entre 1880 et 1905 par exemple
plus de 700 congrégations religieuses
catholiques qui ont été fermés manu
militari avec déportation parfois des
croyants qui refusaient la loi
républicaine ils ont été envoyés en
allemagne en belgique
à un moment donné ceux qui refusent les
lois de la république et de la laïcité
doivent aller ailleurs les etats unis la
grande bretagne les accueillerons s'ils
veulent absolument avoir une vie que ne
tarissent et j'espère qu'il y aura un
personnel politique qui prendra cette
ligne là car ce serait aller totalement
à l'encontre de l'identité de la france
je vous donne le point de vue de
nouveaux internautes sur twitter où vous
êtes invités à répondre à cette question
la france at elle abandonné milla vous
répondez oui à 64%
ce n'est pas tout à fait l'avis de paul
hh sur youtube
je suis d'accord avec tous les propos de
me la mets si elle est protégée c'est
qu'on s'occupe d'elle a elle aussi de se
faire oublier
chardon bleu considère au contraire que
c'est bien dommage de céder à ces
religions et puis
la vie sous toujours sur youtube de
steve gagnent d'affaires milla est
l'illustration parfaite des limites de
l'intersexualité de gauche à vouloir
conjuguer tolérance et promotion de
l'islam et des lgbt en même temps
laurent alexandre georges kuzmanovic se
rappeler cet épisode historique qui a
été là là le traitement difficile des
catholiques au début du siècle mais
c'était à l'intérieur d'une même
religion et sélestat c'est l'état laïc
qui encapsule est la religion catholique
et qui au travers de toutes les lois
jusqu'en 1905 organisait la laïcisation
de la société
là c'est pas la même chose si on faisait
vis-à-vis des islamistes un peu
turbulent sur le sol français ce qu'on a
fait avec les lois de la troisième
république
on aurait la guerre civile là on n'est
pas à l'intérieur d'une même religion
on est religion contre religions
monothéistes donc là on a un conflit ou
une guerre de religion qui j'espère ne
débouchera pas sur des choses violentes
on n'est pas du tout dans la situation
de la troisième république il n'y avait
pas de religion dans la troisième
république il n'y avait qu'une religion
et l'état laïc souhaitait limiter le
pouvoir des catholiques
là c'est tout à fait différent on est
une religion en déclin extrêmement
rapide qu'est le catholicisme et que
l'on sait et beaucoup d'entre nous sont
libres penseurs ou athées et puis on à
la montée en flèche de croyances du fait
d'une modification démographie que
absolument inédite dans l'histoire de
france
donc en réalité si on voulait faire ce
que le petit père combes a fait
il ya 120 ans on aurait la guerre civile
dans l'est dans le 9 3 jean né de la
conviction
donc en réalité le politique ne va pas
renouveler la société avec sa vision
laïc et athée je pense que la société va
faire comme jean luc mélenchon
elle va accepter le changement de
paradigme et le fait que la france de
demain ne peut pas être aussi laïque est
aussi libre penseuse que la gauche
progressiste l'espérait en 1970 taillon
la trahison de la gauche qui est venu
islamo-gauchiste ce qui n'est pas le cas
de de notre ami est très significative
mélenchon est toujours apte et mélenchon
n'est pas devenu croyance est pas
devenue une grenouille de bénitier
il ne croit toujours pas en dieu sauf
qu'il est devenu islamo-gauchiste parce
que sinon il perd sa circonscription
est-ce que vous pensez que
7 on aurait pu écrire l'histoire
autrement c'est à dire que si la france
avait été depuis le début de la vague
d'immigration musulmane au début des
années 70 plus plus plus plus exigeantes
en termes d'assimilation nous n'aurions
pas les manifestations d'intolérance
voire de violence que subit mais il a
aujourd'hui
oui je pense que la simulation a été
malmené durant ces trois quatre
dernières décennies pour tout un tas de
facteurs mais par rapport à ce que vous
disiez le problème c'est que dans un
contexte de recul de la république de
recul des services publics de
paupérisation de la population en
augmentation du chômage
ddd classé divers et variés ce n'est pas
que l'islam politique devient menaçant
là on a une montée qui a commencé en
amérique latine mais qui en train de
venir dans nos banlieues des
évangélistes
on voit que le communautarisme porté par
des gens comme rokhaya diallo soit
disant lieu contre nous et blanc contre
les pats blanc n'a aucun sens l'iffhs
ils font exprès l'impasse sur l'une des
conséquences du communautarisme soit
guère les affrontements intra
communautaires et malgré les marocains
étaient ces algériens qui est des sss
les tunisiens et les noirs les les
les asiatiques les asiatiques font des
manifestations parce qu'il frotte est ce
qu'ils se font attaquer par des jeunes
racailles issus des quartiers qui veut
se faire un chien enfin bon le jeune
cycliste noir on a vu ce décès n'était
d'esclaves par exane à thouars des
membres de la communauté sikh la ville
au contraire si on n'a pas ce n'est pas
radical républicain et laïque
on va avoir une moralisation de la
société française avec des gens qui vont
vouloir entrer en conflit et l'émergence
dans la droite identitaire de mouvement
justement de génération identitaire mais
aussi de d'humoristes comme papa si tôt
montrent que tout cela est en train de
réveiller des gens qui ne peuvent que se
finir par se faire la guerre les uns les
autres sur le territoire national la
guerre civile se fera de toute façon
dont je pense au contraire qu'il faut
est parfaitement radical calmer tout le
monde et dire comme le disait fort bien
hugo le
l'église chez elles les tâches lui et
vous pensez pas que ce serait
aujourd'hui impossible parce que il y
aurait des émeutes si on impose par
exemple si on imposait des règles de
laïcité plus forte en matière par
exemple vestimentaire où il voudra sait
pas qu'il est trop tard non mais s'il
est trop tard ça finira mal
encore une fois parce qu'il va pas y
avoir un islamiste en ce sera plus plein
de courant déjà entre les sunnites et
les chiites mais entre les communautés
religieuses les turcs ne sont pas
d'accord avec avec les maghrébins il ya
plein de conflits qui n'intéressent que
ce qu'ils pensent qu'ils se penchent
dessus puis lors d'affrontements avec
les évangélistes sur quoi une fois ce
sera nécessaire à un moment ou à un
autre sans esprit polémique
on peut quand même reconnaître que même
si les évangélistes gagne en influence
y a pas de menace de mort si vous
critiquez la bible améliorée bien sûr
mais en parlant de mila récemment il ya
un humoriste qui sur une radio publique
a fait un sketch chanter sur sur
l'homosexualité du christ c'est grave le
est assez pauvre intellectuellement bon
la position s'est collé serré liberté
d'expression il blasphème et c'est très
bien
évidemment il n'est pas il n'ya pas les
conséquences que cas ce genre de
blasphème sur sur le prophète ou le
coran mais je pense que ça viendra et on
trouvera des fous qui considérons qu'ils
sont gravement atteints dans leur foi et
vu ce qui se passe avec les évangélistes
en amérique latine je ne vois pas
pourquoi ça va pas un jour en france
mais bien évidemment ce n'est pas le cas
actuellement